as more states legalize recreational
marijuana use another part of the
cannabis plant has found a market niche
CBD short for cannabidiol is a molecule
that can be derived from hemp or
cannabis since it doesn't contain THC it
won't get you high CBD has become a
trendy ingredient in wellness products
because of its purported therapeutic
benefits it can even be found in dog
treats to help with canine anxiety I
wanted to put this into a format that I
thought could be mainstream and I
thought beverage would be the best
format for that Jonathan Epis is the
founder of vibes a company that makes
CBD drinks that are sold in nearly 250
US grocery stores coffee shops
restaurants and hotels uppers launched
his los angeles-based company in 2017
after using CBD oils to treat his own
anxiety but the products he sells are
illegal in California I really didn't
think too much about the regulations
around CBD because CBD oil was being
sold in grocery stores here in LA and it
was like kind of everywhere in January
2019 episode officials from the
California Department of Public Health
showed up to one of his Los Angeles
warehouses where they confiscated 140
thousand dollars worth of vibes
beverages the other thing that really
was tough about it is when the
inspectors went into the warehouse they
asked the warehouse to turn over all the
shipping logs and they use that
information and to go after our
co-packer up in Northern California and
so for basically two months we haven't
been able to sell vibes which is costing
us hundreds of thousands of dollars
California is just one of many states
where CBD sales are legally murky but
law clearly allows for the sale of
cannabis derived CBD products but items
that contain the hemp version of the
molecule are prohibited the Department
of Public Health here is of the view
that CBD can't be put in foods beverages
animal foods
you name it basically many different
kinds of commercial products in this
state Griffin thorn a cannabis lawyer
with Harris breakn says California's
stance is part of a larger trend but it
is kind of interesting that you have
marijuana which is still federally
illegal and there's a path towards sales
for companies that want to actually make
and sell marijuana products whereas CBD
is derived from a plant that's no longer
federally illegal but there are a ton of
roadblocks and there's
zero clarity on how to do it for many
products just months after a pers
launched his company the California
Department of Public Health adopted the
Food and Drug Administration's stance on
CBD and declared that products
containing the compound cannot be sold
by unlicensed retailers further
complicating the regulatory landscape I
was confused because CBD had been sold
in California for several years there's
one getting bigger and all of a sudden
they were coming out saying that we
couldn't put this in food and beverages
so it was like what what changed it's a
strange phenomenon when you can go down
the street in LA and there's a cannabis
store on every corner selling weed or
across the street and buy alcohol and
get drunk and drive a car but you can't
drink you know CBD like many CBD
entrepreneurs uppers continued selling
his product while requesting that the
state provide legal clarification his
pleas have gone unanswered uppers was
hopeful that the passage of the 2018
u.s. farm bill removing hemp from the
Controlled Substances list would
establish that his products are fully
legal that wasn't the case it wasn't
until after the farm bill passed that
California became a lot more aggressive
and actually going after companies here
in California that were producing CBD
products it's just still kind of delay
overs from Prohibition kenny morrison a
cannabis industry veteran who runs VCC
brands and serves as president of the
California cannabis Manufacturers
Association sees parallels between
today's CBD market and the early days of
recreational marijuana the retail model
of cannabis being sold at a storefront
in order for that to become accepted and
commonplace people had to sort of break
the law or interpret the law in a new
way in order to make it happen and we're
seeing that with CBD as well so it's
kind of ironic that now cannabis is
super regulated and CBD still isn't yet
cannabis paved the way for CBD with
consumer sales of CBD products projected
to top two billion dollars by 2020
lawmakers in several states including
California are pushing for bipartisan
legislation that would legalize the use
of CBD in food beverage and cosmetic
products what's happened with the state
kind of clamping down on this and we
after it is it's really brought the
industry together now we've got the
politicians in California involved and
they're very tuned in to this
fortunately there's a lot of support for
the bill California's CBD bill is
currently making its way through this
date house the move Epis and others hope
will clean up the regulatory mess left
over from Prohibition
[Music]